des petits grains blancs vous savez
comment ça ça s'appelle ah vous ne
connaissez pas le mot c'est riz du riz
r
i non
i r i Z ah la gramère française la htise
des enfants à l'école ces cours qui n'en
finissent pas où l'on se dit que notre
langue est trop compliquée mais tout le
monde n'y est pas allergique lors de la
Journée européenne des langues les
étudiants étrangers s'y colent avec
plaisir par de petits ateliers c'est
l'occasion pour eux d'apprendre de
nouveau
pour exemple et je ne connais pas avant
et CR le CR le CR de la rache pour les
étrangers le plus compliqué est de faire
la différence entre prononciation et
transposition sur la feuille c'est
un oui pourquoi qu'est-ce qui est dur
c'est la langue française qui est
compliquée et oui c'est compliqué parce
que c'est si tu appren comment tout les
parle après je dois appris comment je
contrairement aux Français les étrangers
sont pleins d'enthousiasme lorsqu'il
s'agit de Grammare française il sont
très motivé parce qu'il déjà il pour
beaucoup c'est un rêve de venir en
France quelques mois donc quand ils sont
là ils ont envie de tout faire pour
apprendre un maximum il y a tous les
niveaux en fait il y en a qui arrivent
qui parlent pas un mot et il y en a qui
arrivent qui parlent très très bien
français donc voilà mais la progression
en général est assez rapide certains
sont plus à l'aise à l'écrit comme les
Chinois et inversement les Espagnols et
les Italiens trs BAV nous ressemble le
serel le centre de ressources et espace
langue ouvre ses portes le vendredi 28
septembre il permet l'apprentissage
d'une dizaine de langues
étrangèr